people of the internet hogwarts legacy
fans welcome back ratchet reckons who
are here i'm just a dad who loves games
in the stories they tell and ever since
the little shot of the hud i almost said
leaked but it didn't leak we just didn't
realize it was there at least most of us
didn't i've seen some people in the
comments say oh i saw it all along but a
lot of us missed it now we went back
we've seen it we've broken it down i
want you to be a part of this
conversation with me because i am
literally trying to figure this out and
i need your help so i think a key
moment in the trailer is if you go to
around 757 we're gonna go here and watch
it together but here's what i want you
to listen for our character casts four
spells in very rapid succession that's
been one of the big things with this
game is that it seems like the combat
it's so fluid it's like a dance and the
spells they can just sort of chain off
one another okay maybe 756.
all right so
if you play it slowly or if you just
listen very carefully i clearly hear
accio i hear descendo i hear confringo
and then just as it starts to cut away
i'm pretty sure that i hear depal so so
that would be four spells that we can
chain together
very quickly now i'm going to jump back
because i want to call your attention to
something else in this shot as well
we're going to go right around the same
spot maybe a little bit pat yeah 758 i
think will be a good spot look over here
on the right side r1 we see this barrel
and we see r1
and r1 is used throughout the trailer to
cast a pugno so i want to take you to
another spot here okay this one we're
going to go to 642 and i just want to
prove to you that it is 100
r1 right here i think we can all see
that and then you're going to very
clearly hear the character say a pugno
okay now this time i want you to listen
to what the narrator says after it
because i think that is also key so
let's play it one more time here
counter-attack with powerful stunning
charms allowing you to follow up with
extended spell combinations
counter attack with powerful stunning
charms allowing you to follow up with
what do you say extended powerful
stunning charms allowing you to follow
up with extended spell combinations yeah
allowing you to follow up with extended
spell
combinations so that a pugno there is
basically like a counter attack it seems
that is how they're handling it so it's
almost like a pugno is in its own
separate category all right so now we're
gonna go to another trailer this is also
an official trailer the next-gen
immersion trailer and this is the one
where they talk about the light bar but
i'm gonna let it play here
and feel the sensation of flight okay we
got that here here comes the big one
though right after this haptic feedback
okay i lied not yet not yet feel the
force of magic right there adaptive
triggers and when they say adaptive
triggers we clearly see the character up
here casting i don't know stupify
expelliarmus maybe i'm gonna go 0.25
speed so we got the little graphic down
here at the bottom oh i need to turn off
the music
adaptive triggers and so then they they
go directly into this so it's like okay
is that also casting the spells right
here i think so now you see here we just
saw three spells used very quickly so
let me see if we can actually get some
audio on this one maybe we hear the
characters saying these as well
[Music]
okay so i'm not hearing anything at all
with the character on this one so we
don't hear them calling out the spells i
mean that's glacious right pretty
clearly
the glacius has to be glaciers there and
then first we have this uh red so maybe
like a stupefy
and that one just doesn't seem to really
have a lot of effect against the troller
i mean it kind of like does it stagger
him a little bit or let's just make him
angry because then he just immediately
charges but then we cast glacius here
that helps to slow him down a bit and
then we're immediately gonna go to this
shot right here now this one we hear in
the main gameplay trailer we hear the
character say accio so anytime you see
this little grabbing of the chain here
and it kind of extends out like a little
almost looks like a golden rope and i've
heard some people speculate that maybe
this is carpe retractum which i'm
replaying through harry potter and the
prisoner of azkaban and that is a spell
that they use in that game and that one
does indeed act in a more rope-like
fashion than accio i mean they're very
similar accio is you know known as the
summoning charm we see harry use that in
the book to summon his broomstick when
he's doing the first task and goblet of
fire so typically you think of that as
more summoning an object whereas carpe
retractum is supposed to be more like an
actual rope and that seems to be
it definitely looks more like carpe
retractum but there's no doubt we hear
the character say accio for that
particular
and then we have the whole hud thing
which i honestly like the more i think
about this i know we all kind of said
this is definitely a placeholder we're
mostly thinking placeholder in terms of
the icons themselves but maybe this
whole format even was a placeholder i
don't think and i could be wrong about
this but i don't think this is some
secret that they hid in there and were
hoping we would find later i really
think it was just a mistake i don't
think this was meant to be in here not
that they necessarily even wanted to
hide it but just that it wasn't ready
this wasn't something that was meant to
be shown and for anyone who's done video
editing you know how it works when you
do like a cross dissolve transition i
would be willing to bet that's almost
exactly what happened here because
sometimes it can show a little bit of a
shot that you don't intend and i mean
we're talking just a few frames here so
it was a very
easy mistake to make so i say all that
just to caution you with i don't know
how much stock we should put in that but
knowing that we've seen this and knowing
that it's out there i do think we should
try and at least figure out how this
fits in with everything we've seen on
screen in the trailer combining that
with the fact that we know r2 is going
to be used to cast at least some spells
but then we also have a very clear
example of r1 being used to cast a spell
at least in the case of a pugno and
perhaps instead of thinking this in
terms of just spells we should think
more of like traditional video game
controls like what would they be like
right you would have your dodge button
you would have your jump button you
would use the joystick to control the
movement of your character and then
maybe you would have like a fire button
where in most cases the fire button is
not going to be the same as the counter
move button so to me at least it would
make sense if a pug note is always kind
of mapped to r1 but then that begs the
question are there other spells like
that i could see protegos certainly
fitting into that category as well
protego 100 is going to be one of those
things that you have to hit just as the
spell collides with you to block it i
mean it's going to be a timing thing but
what will we use for that will it be l2
would be l1 or will it be one of these
spells that we have to set in whatever
sort of spell management system we have
here so in my other video on this we
talked a little bit about this right one
here i kind of threw out some guesses of
what that could be and then a lot of you
in the comments said it's most likely a
spell on cooldown which i think makes
sense and again i just don't know how
much stock we should put in this little
white bar i mean a lot of people are
thinking that as like the slowly refill
of the spell to say when you can use it
again but in terms of how you actually
activate and or use these spells
i think that's the most interesting bit
here i'm inclined to believe that these
are a spell selector of sorts you select
your spell by pressing up down left or
right on the d-pad and then you use r2
to cast whichever one is the active
spell but here's the thing it does not
appear that any of these are active so
to speak so then you have to wonder is
it more like the old harry potter games
where you actually map these to one of
the face buttons so maybe the bottom one
could be the x on the playstation the
one on the left could be square and i
could see that being the case too except
for the fact that we've already seen in
the next gen immersion trailer that r2
is going to be used to cast some spells
and so i think r2 is used for these
types of spells right here but how do we
select them and enable them that is the
big question and the thing is it has to
be very quick very fluid we go back to
that shot that we started out with our
character cast those spells so quickly i
mean just in rapid succession accio
descendo confringo and then just as it
cuts away again to pulso this is one of
those things that can make or break the
game i mean this is going to determine
how the game actually feels to play when
we're in combat we're engaging in all
these different activities where we're
going to have to go through puzzles and
then there's probably gonna be enemies
to face along the way how this spell
system works is going to go a long way
at determining how much enjoyment we
have while playing it now one game i
mentioned in my last video that i want
to talk a little bit more about how it
works is ratchet and clank because i
think this would actually be a really
good example of a possible way for them
to do this and to have those four button
hotkeys but then also to have a spell
wheel type of management system as well
where we could quickly switch between a
different spell if we didn't have it in
our hotkeys and when i say hotkeys i'm
talking about the four face buttons or
four d-pad buttons we really aren't sure
but i'm going by that hud that we've
seen so here's a screenshot of the
button layout for ratchet and clank and
i want you to pay particular attention
here to triangle so if you hold this
down it will bring up the full wheel now
if you've played ratchet and clank games
before you know you unlock a lot of
weapons so it will bring up all the
weapons that you have and you can select
any of them very quickly but in addition
to that they also have where you can
select shortcuts here using the d-pads
you can use any of the d-pad buttons
here as a shortcut instead then they
have circle as a dash ability we also
know we're going to have a dash ability
in hogwarts i can see x for jump square
for melee r2 for fire r1 for hover
hoverboot and then l2 for aiming so i do
think we could see something similar in
hogwarts legacy i'm trying to think of
all the other buttons that we know we're
going to need dash is obviously one of
them i don't think we've had jump
confirmed yet i don't know if we can
jump in hogwarts legacy or not i would
expect that we can and so jump seemingly
is always mapped to x and like ratchet
and clank here square is usually some
sort of melee ability in most action
games i could honestly geek out about
this all day but i wanna hear what you
guys think let me know in the comments
below we still have plenty of questions
remaining about hogwarts legacy here are
seven of my biggest questions that i
still have about the game check that
video out on the right side of your
screen now as always thank you all so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon